Stellt sich raus, es waren gar keine gefährlichen Raubtiere, es war eine Jazzband, sondern es war eine fucking Jazzband.
Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Oh, dazu.
Herzlich willkommen zum Dino-Cast mit Stephanosaurus Ticeratops.
Und Florentin Lataniensis Argentinius. Und natürlich heute bei uns das Buch aufgemacht haben Johannes und Filine. Vielen Dank, es fällt auf, dass immer mehr Co-Produktionen tatsächlich hier die Intros stellen, wir haben keine Michis, keine Alex, keine Nikos mehr, sondern oft Co-Produktionen, wo sich Leute zusammentun, wo Menschen vielleicht auch irgendwie durch die Musik zusammenkommen, was mich immer total freut, wenn wir als kleines Musiknachwuchsprojekt, was wir mittlerweile ja primär sind, Podcast ist ja nur noch ein störendes Anhängsel, es geht ja quasi nur noch um die Neuentdeckungen sozusagen der internationalen Musikszene. Und heute Johannes und Feline, Feline, haben hier noch ein bisschen den Jazz-Kontrabass rausgeholt. Ich liebe ja Jazz, es gibt unfassbar viele verschiedene Arten von Jazz, es gibt Trompete, es gibt Saxophon, es gibt... So, ich hab's gefunden. Okay, Gott, Jazz. Es gibt unfassbar viele verschiedene Arten von Jazz. Es gibt Trompete, es gibt Saxophon. Ich hab's gefunden. Okay, Gott, danke. Okay, Stefan Tietze ist mit dabei, herzlich willkommen. Ich hab's gefunden, ich hab das Video gefunden, du kannst aufhören, diese Brücke zu schlagen. Aber das finde ich so Momente immer, die finde ich sehr beeindruckend bei dir. Und ich finde es unironisch, du bist eines der grössten Moderationstalente, die dieses Land jemals hervorgebracht hat. Dieses Jahrtausend. die dieses Land jemals hervorgebracht hat. Aber das meine ich ganz unironisch und ohne eines der grössten moderations talenten dieses land jemals hervorgebracht hat das ist ganz unironisch und ohne doppelten boden wir können nicht so die folge anfangen wo sollen wir dann noch hingehen weil es war gerade genau dieses geplägt dieses frank elstnerische elstnerische geprägt ja aber guck mal allein die geste wenn du die diese plapper geste macht was ist denn moderieren anderes als das ja so siehstgeste. So siehst du mich. Das bin ich für dich. Die ganze Zeit. Und dann will man das so lange die Fresse halten, weil ich das Video gefunden habe und zack bist du fertig mit dem, was du gesagt hast. Was möchtest du uns präsentieren? Du möchtest ein Video zeigen in diesem Podcast? Okay, das wird interessant. Ne, es ist tatsächlich ein Soundbite, was das natürlich nicht lädt, weil Forscher haben herausgefunden, wie der T-Rex wirklich klang. Und das wollen wir als großer T-Rex-Podcast, das sind die Dinosaurier, gerade was diese neuen Bewegungen angeht, der Dinosaurier wird entmaskulinisiert. Wir stehen dem skeptisch gegenüber auf jeden Fall, aber wir sind natürlich auch Wissenschaftler letzten Endes. Unser Reddit wurde geflutet quasi von dieser neuen Errungenschaft der Wissenschaft, die es immer wieder schaffen, alt und tot Geglaubtes zum Leben zu erwecken. Wie in diesem Fall dieser T-Rex, der ja schon lange, lange tot ist, aber sich jetzt noch mal zu Wort meldet. Was würde ein T-Rex über unsere heutige politische Situation sagen? Wie würde er sie einordnennen? Dein Dopp, halt deine Fresse.
So, und wir hören jetzt einen, ich glaube, das ist es nicht, ich glaube, wir werden jetzt, ich bin an einem Scam aufgesessen, wir gucken mal, wir hören mal. Risky Rick Roll jetzt.
Oh, er Briten reden. Also wir hatten ja schon mal den alten ägyptischen Pharao hier im Podcast als Gast, der lange rekonstruiert wurde, wo es lange ... Rach me, Kach, Kach, Fee. Wo es lange rekonstruiert wurde mit Stimmbändern bei Mumien und am Ende war es so ein Okay, gut. Gut auch zu wissen, dass unsere Wissenschaftsetats, unsere Töpfe, da fliessen unsere Töpfe hin, Stefan. Also es war ein holpriger Start. Ich wollte nur sagen, es wurde jetzt rekonstruiert, wie der T-Rex klang, der die ganze Zeit inzwischen hat, ein Federkleid, wundervolle Augenlider und so und grosse Wimpern mit so einem schönen Schwung, mit so einem supercoolen Schwung und so einem Paillettenkleid an. Und er hat auch nicht mehr gejagt oder so, sondern er hat Aas gegessen. Genau, Aas. Er konnte gerade mal so schnell laufen, wie ein erwachsener Mensch joggt, geht, also etwas, oh, ich hab der Bus, der bummelt, ja. Das war ungefähr die Bummelgeschwindigkeit. Jemand, der durch einen Rewe geht und genau weiß, was er will. Richtig. Das ist die Geschwindigkeit eines T-Rex. Und er kann auch nicht, er ist auch nicht gerannt, sondern er ist mehr, weil er so schwer war und so behäbig, hat er zum Beispiel immer, muss er immer beide Beine am Boden haben oder so. Das macht nicht richtig Sinn. Er ist so, wie wenn man so mit Socken über den Boden schaffelt, einfach so nach vorne gerutscht. Wie Kinder, die zum ersten Mal Gehversuch machen. So jedenfalls, die Wissenschaft macht uns das seit Jahren kaputt, den T-Rex. Genau, den geliebten T-Rex aus Jurassic Park, den wir lieben und als Stofftierer haben. So klang der T-Rex. Genau, und jetzt nämlich kam dieser Sound ans Tageslicht, den wir gerade nicht gehört haben, weil Briten die ganze Zeit drüber gebrabbelt haben, weil die sich gerne, gerne reden hören. It's absolutely amazing. It's absolutely fantastic. It's the first time ever that we're able to hear such a sound. Isn't it great? Video vorbei. Es kommt dann nicht noch mal ein Sing. Absolutely astonishing. Stunning. Are you mental not to hear this sound? Are you having a laugh? Ja, jedenfalls der Sound, ich muss ihn kurz so nachmachen, weil der klingt ziemlich ... Wir können es technisch einfach gerade nicht produzieren, anscheinend? Es ist die der grösste enttäuschendste Spannungsaufbau in der Geschichte des Podcasting. Ich finde es wirklich nicht, weil das Ding ist ja, unsere Handys filmen uns ja neuerdings, sonst kann ich sie einfach da finden, weil da wurde es nämlich geschickt. Ich finde sie so gerade nicht. Unsere Handys filmen uns? Ja, das kann man auf Patreon.com. Hier, auf unserem Reddit ist es einfach. Ich drücke jetzt einfach drauf. Also im Reddit ist es ja. Ja. Sau geil. Richtig gut. Scary. Isn't this absolutely astonishing? Those are sounds that haven't been heard for millions of years, and it's absolutely amazing how the modern sounds, well, yes, that the past is never really bad, but it will come back one day, and that's what we're doing.
The righteous man knows what I said. Es hat, ich finde, es hat schon was sehr cooles. Man muss natürlich jetzt noch wissen, was diese Geräusche bedeuten. Ist es jetzt Kampf, Schrei, Brunft? Aber gerade dieses so geil, ist wie so ein Star Wars Tier. Aber es hat auch was von diesem Alien-Sound, wie zum Beispiel Arrival oder so, hat man ja auch immer so dieses Bööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööööö Ich finde, wir müssen wieder so eine Skala machen, wo wir sagen, haben wir Image-Schaden oder Image-Gewinn für den T-Rex und aktuell, glaube ich, steigen die Kurse. Also, kauft jetzt.
Ich finde es macht ja fast noch gruseliger, wenn dieses Ding, was diese Geräusche hat, ein Paillettenkleid anhat.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da wird es gruselig. Even more iconic.
Hat er was von so einem flamboyant Bond-Bösewicht.
Ja.
Ist ja auch wieder geil.
Das macht ihn ja fast noch unberechenbarer.
Weil wenn er so auftritt und hat so lange French Nails und so den Wimpernschwung und macht dann.
Jetzt, man, T-Rex ist da wieder da! T-Rex ist back! T-Rex ist zurück, man, geil! So, und ich habe natürlich dann gesagt, ich muss jetzt wissenschaftlich rangehen. Was macht bei Tieren dieser Sound? Angenommen, ein Tier hört diesen Sound, weil die sprechen ja in etwa alle die gleiche Sprache. Es ist andere Dialekte, aber im Grunde man versteht es nicht. Und dann habe ich dem T-Rex, diesen T-Rex hat einem Hund vorgespielt, weil ich dachte, wie reagiert der Hund?
Keine Reaktion.
Und dann merkt man, es sind zu viele Millionen Jahre dazwischen.
Es ist zu weit weg, der Hund hat kein Verständnis mehr für dieses. Aber es war eher trotzdem diese kopfquerlegen Geste gemacht im Sinne von, ich brauche mehr Informationen, ich höre was. Naja, ich meine, der Hund ist ja das Säugetier und hat damit den Dinosaurier offensichtlich besiegt.
Ins Messer laufen lassen.
Das ist ja quasi du,
der hört ja hier eine unterlegene Spezies,
der sagt ja, das ist wie wenn eine Katze eine Maus hört,
das ist so, ja,
habe ich schon, habe ich schon, besiegt,
ist für mich nichts. Selbst der kleinste,
dusseligste, unfähigste,
erbärmlichste Hund hört einen T-Rex
und sagt, ja, habe ich besiegt, ist kein Problem,
dem habe ich einfach die Eier geklaut.
Weißt du, der klingt, pass mal auf, der klingt furchteinflössend, aber du kannst ihm einfach die Eier klauen. Du hast ihm Eier? Du siehst ihm, ich habe ihm alle Eier geklaut. Du hast ihm jetzt gerade alle Eier geklaut? Schönes Dino-Omelette. Na klar. Joey, du kannst ihm nicht einfach die Eier klauen. Du kannst dich ständig allen Leuten die Eier klauen. Er ist gross und blablabla. Aber wenn der nicht da... Oh, ja, wir können weglaufen. Wo sind meine ... Oh, ein Tiefweiter ist auch noch vorbeigeflogen. War eine wilde Zeit damals auf jeden Fall. Aber dass tatsächlich die Säugetiere gewonnen haben am Ende, weiss ich nicht. Ich find's komisch. Meinst du, da gab es Walbetrug oder irgendwie so, hat jemand nachgeholfen, Ricked, dass die Säugetiere wirklich gewinnen mit ihrem Säugen? Aber Eier sind halt, Eier sind Drecks. Säugen, es ist doch offensichtlich unterlegen. So ein Ei ist gelegt und dann... Genau, dann kann es geklaut werden. Wogegen Säugetieren das Ei im Bauch? Ja, und Säugetiere, die klängen man dann noch so an dir. Ja, genau, und können nicht einfach geklala... Mom, Mom, genau, er hängt an den Brüsten, an den Zitzen der Mama, er hängt dieses ängstliche kleine Säugetier und es würde von außen bedachten, es kommt so ein fertiges kleines T-Rexchen aus dem Ei gekrochen, sieht für mich überlegene aus. Ja, stimmt. Zumal das Ei ja auch beschützt ist. Kleiner Tipp von mir an die Eiwälder
draußen, macht so kleine Spikes ans
Ei, dann klaut man es nicht. Geil, dass sie nicht geklaut werden.
Dass man dessen nicht geklaut werden. Es kann einfach Igel haben es raus.
Ja, ja. Aber gut,
ist natürlich für die Geburt ein bisschen unangenehm.
Also ich meine, klar,
ich weiß nicht, ob, Entschuldigung, ich weiß auch nicht, ob mir Geburt sagt,
beim Ei legen, Entschuldigung,
ich will jetzt nicht die unserer Eier legenden
Hörerinnen und Hörer hier
auf dem falschen Fuss erwischen, aber das ist natürlich ein Problem, aber du kannst natürlich nach der Geburt dann noch so was hinkleben. Oder die zumindest tarnen, ich meine die sind weiss mit gelben Flecken, ich meine sorry, aber mach die doch irgendwie grün braun oder so. Da steht Steal Me da drauf. I dare you to eat me.
Ich meine, was war die Idee dahinter? Kann man das nicht in so klassischem Camouflage-Look? Anderer Tipp, wenn ihr die Spikes nicht wollt, weil die euch bei der Geburt wehtun, sorry, schreibt einfach drauf, mindestens haltbar bis Ende 2018. So, dann geht auch niemand mehr dran. Niemand wird da rangehen. Es wird sogar niemand rangehen, wenn da stehen würde, Juni 2023. Alles Auch zurecht. Alles, was ein Haltbarkeitsdatum hat, ist schon mal erstmal schwierig. Ja, genau. Oder ein Baum. Ich meine, klar, vielleicht fällt das ein oder andere runter. Ich meine, Vögel sind ja die überlebenden Dinosaurier. Und was ist der grosse Unterschied? Die legen Eier im Baum, wo der kleine Hund, der Dachs nicht rankommt. Ja, der Komodowaran legt auch Eier mitten am Boden.
Ja, aber der liegt auf einer Insel.
Legt auch Eier an den Weg.
Direkt auf die Autobahn legt er seine Eier und dann,
Och Mensch, das hat der im Japaner kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt wird der im Japaner kaputt gemacht.
Und warum lebst du noch?
Warum machst du den Komodowaran so nah?
Ja gut, weil ein Trottel ist. Sorry, weil ein paar Trottel.
Der isst Menschen. It eats people. Ja, it eats people. It's an animal. People. It eats people. I like Komodo-Dragons. I'm a clam guy. I basically only eat clams. Das ist der Junge, der ist von Recher's Therapy. Ich mag unsere Quellenangaben mittlerweile, dass wir das wirklich einbauen. I'm a Quellen-Guy. I'm a Quellen-Guy. I basically only eat Quellen. Only do Citation. Was ich toll finde, ist dieses Video, Recessory, man macht Videos über Kinder, interviewt Kinder, ganz tolle, süße Art, und da gibt es den Komodo Dragon, das Komodo Dragon Kid. Ich finde das so geil, dass so ein Kind über sich selbst sagt i'm a clam guy das habe ich noch nie von einem kind gehört dass es so über sich selber so i'm a clam guy that's that's who i am i basically only eat clams ich finde das so cool essen was eigentlich älteren vorbehalten ist und alleine er sagt, ich esse quasi ausschliesslich Muscheln. Welches Kind sagt das? Aber dieses, wo lebt der vor allem? Boston? Vor allem, ich finde, das sagen Leute, die eigentlich alles schon probiert haben. Und da sagen, ich habe alles probiert, ich habe alles probiert, ich habe ein Crime und das ist ein Kind, das sagt, ich finde das so lustig. Aber er wäre es genauso lustig, wenn er sagen würde, ich habe ein pasta guy. Auch, aber nicht ganz so lustig. Clem ist noch am besten, weil es so ungewöhnlich ist. Es potenziert auch diese eh schon eine Aussage wie jemand, der so sagt, ach, wem mache ich was vor. Ja, ja. I'm a pasta guy. Aber das potenziert es noch mehr, weil es wieder so eine Dinge ist, was Älteren vorbehalten ist. Muscheln ist so ein Seniorenessen. Ich glaube, ich habe Muscheln bis ich 20 war nie gegessen. Na doch, vielleicht so diese in Nudeln oder so drin, vielleicht. Das ist das Letzte, was ich jetzt gerade für mich entdeckt habe, sind teilweise... Wegen deines Angelscheins sind Muscheln Fische? Nee, Muscheln sind Schalentiere, Wirbellose, legen die Eier. Und du findest es okay, die danach zu kategorisieren, was sie nicht haben? Du bist ein Flügelloser. Stefan ist ja in der Kategorie der Flügellosen. Moment, warum kategorierst du mich etwas nach dem, was ich nicht habe? Aber hast du keine Flügel, oder? Oder habe ich es dir nur übersehen? Vielleicht habe ich es übersehen. Nee, ich habe keinen Flügel. Lass uns doch mal nachgucken. Aber ich habe gesäugt. Nee, ist okay, aber lass uns doch mal nachgucken. Ich wollte gesäugt. Ja. Nämlich doch so, so einfach, nach dem, was ich mache. Nee, du bist ein Nicht-Eierleger. Du bist nicht Eierleger. Das ist echt super gemein. Das ist richtig gemein, finde ich. Wirbellos. Wirbellos. Weil es ist ja auch vielleicht ganz geil, dass die keine Wirbel haben. Das ist so die Arroganz von uns Menschen. Wir nennen euch glibberige Glibbertiere. Glibfaces. Da müsste ich jetzt nochmal mit dem Hohen Rat. Das seid ihr. Wenn ihr ein Geräusch hört, wer ihr... Ja, hör mal, nee, das geht für mich zu weit. Nee, mach mir das nicht Gesicht, nicht vor allem. Nee, ich müsste nochmal mit dem Hohen Rat Rücksprache halten. Aber Glibber... Ja, glibber, schleim mich hin zu deinem Hohen Rat. Ja, hast du eine Ahnung, wie selten wir tagen, wie die Schnecken brauchen, bis die Muscheln da an? Wenn die Tür so klein wäre, wie so ein Schlüsselloch, könnt ihr euch dazu durchschleimt? Ja, was nicht schlecht ist. Nee, ich sag nur, warum könnt ihr das? Weil ihr keine Wirbel habt. Ich sag auch nicht, dass es schlecht ist. Ja, genau. Du bist an eine Wirbel gebunden. Wirbelknecht. Du bist ein Wirbelknecht.
Aber ich kann... Okay, pass auf.
Ich will aufrecht laufen. Ich kann nirgendwo hin.
Hallo, was ist das denn für ein Gesicht? Ich kann nur überall hin.
Ich kann nur unter der Tür nicht durch. Ich muss überall spärig durch mit meiner Wirbel.
Du bist ein Wirbelknecht. Du hängst an deiner Wirbel. Wirbelknecht, Wirbelknecht, Wirbelknecht. Ich will nur sagen, man kann auch sagen, ah, das ist ein defizitloser Mensch. Das wäre was Positives. Wenn du die Angriffen fühlst, du dich wirbellos, vielleicht findest du Wirbel besser, als du zugeben willst. Ah, nö, ich finde es arrogant, aus seiner Perspektive Leute da noch zu definieren, was sie von dir unterscheidet. Guck doch mal, was mich einzigartig macht. Glibberige Glibberscheisse. Ja gut, jetzt ja, okay. Ich meine, bis der, bis der, bis der, bis der, bis der, ja, ich sehe, ich habe keine Augen, weißt du, das ist halt auch mein Ding. Augenlose. Nee! Aber bis der hohe Rat der wirbellosen tagt, finde ich auch gut, die dann so, wo bleiben die Schnecken? Und dann so Katze Schnecke, die sich kaum bewegt.
Ich stelle mir so ein Jedi-Rad vor. Wo bleiben die Muscheln? Und dann die Muscheln liegt einfach so an der Buseinstelle. Und der Bus fährt ab, die Muscheln einfach. Da geblieben. Keine Chance. Ich stelle mir so ein Jedi-Rad vor, wo dann wie die alle so im Hintergrund sieht man so die Schnellstrassen des Ozeans. Da fliegen so Fische vorbei und so und sie sind aber in diesem grossen hohen Turm und dann hast du da so einen Oktopus sitzen mit seinen acht Armen und er hat eine Kaffeetasse in jeder einzelnen fucking Hand und sitzt dann so und sagt, wir probleme die welt da draußen bezeichnet uns als
wirbel wirbellose und dann sagt der andere das volk der muscheln schätzt diesen vorstoss ja Ja, genau, wir finden das gar nicht so schlecht.
Die Krabben.
Sind die auch Wirbel los? Die klatschen. Haben die irgendwo einen Wirbel? Moment mal, ihr habt doch einen Wirbel! Nein, ich hab keinen Wirbel, das ist mein Panzer, wir haben aussen noch den Chitin-Panzer, aber es ist, zang noch, das ist ja kein Wirbel, Nein, wo sind die Wirbel? Keine Wirbel, nirgendwo, ihr könnt gerne nachsuchen. Es ist kein Racism oder Appropriation, wenn man den Akzent nicht zuordnen kann. Wenn es um Krebs geht. Wenn es um Krebs geht, die einen unzuordnenbaren Akzent sprechen. Okay, spart euch den Kommentar. Hört auf, den Timecode könnt ihr euch wieder vergessen. Streich den. Streich den Timecode. Ich habe gerade eine Mail bekommen und es ist der lustigste... Hat man gar nicht gehört. Tatsächlich hat man es noch nicht gehört, weil ich es prophylaktisch gemutet habe mein Laptop. Denn wir sind stark. Können wir machen diesen Podcast, ich werde mich müde, das zu erwähnen, seit neuneinhalb Jahren. Ja, wir nähern uns dem zehnjährigen Jubiläum. Da haben wir einiges. Inzwischen haben wir nur noch alle drei Folgen Mailgeräusch. Und zwar beginnt diese Mail und es ist der fantastische Anfang aller Zeiten. Guten Tag, Ketize. Leider habe ich heute Morgen schlechte Nachrichten aus Italien bekommen.
Das ist gerade die Mail, die vor ein paar Minuten kam.
Guten Tag, Herr Tietze, leider habe ich heute Morgen schlechte Nachrichten aus Italien bekommen.
Und ich finde das so einen tollen Satz. Heute Morgen auch.
Ja, das ist richtig gut. Ich bin aufgewacht und ich hatte einen Postboten, der gesagt hat, aus Italien.
Und ich konnte am Blick des Postboten schon merken, das sind keine gute Nachrichten. Ciao, ciao Marco. Aber auch, es ist kein Spam, es ist eine Nachricht. Aber ist alles in Ordnung in Italien? Muss man sich Sorgen machen? Sag nicht ein Vulkan. Das würde mich jetzt wirklich beunruhigen, wenn er sagt, schlechte Nachrichten aus Italien, der Vulkan erbrodelt wieder. Das klingt aber auch wie ein Code. Ja, ein bisschen. Ah, Giovanni ist aus dem Knast raus. Okay, der Vesuv ist wieder heiß, der Vesuv läuft warm. Oder Vesuv droht auszubrechen. Ah, also heißt Giovanni droht auszubrechen, aus dem Gefängnis.
Ja, wir nennen ihn doch Vesuv. Es war kein Code. So, hey, psch.
Ich habe einfach nur gesagt, der Vesuv droht auszubrechen.
Aber ist alles okay, ist alles in Ordnung?
Ist alles okay, aber es kamen schlechte Nachrichten heute Morgen aus Italien.
Oh nein. Also das heißt, da ist eine Person, die leitet schlechte Nachrichten weiter. Also das finde ich auch gut. Ist was passiert, dann gibt es den Botschafter und dann gibt es den, der die Nachricht des Botschafters nochmal weiterleitet an dich. Es geht um einen, ich habe einen Kauf getätigt und Italien ist involviert augenscheinlich, was ich nicht wusste.
Okay, aber in welcher Form? Die italienische Regierung, die Land- und Wasserbehörde?
Es ist ein kleiner Kauf. Es gab einen grossen Kauf, es ist ein innerarchitektonischer Kauf. Du hast einen Stuhl gekauft. So was, nee, einen Vorhang, Gardine. Gardine. Ich habe mir was ausgesucht und ich wusste nicht, was Italien war. Heute Morgen kriege ich die Mail, guten Tag, Herr Tietze, leider habe ich heute Morgen schlechte Nachrichten aus Italien bekommen. Was natürlich, aber es ist so, es ist so ein Satz. Es klingt wie der Anfang einer, so einer Verdi-Oper. Heute Morgen kamen schlechte Neuigkeiten aus Italien. So klingt das, aber es geht nur einen fucking Vorhang. Ich überlege mir auch, hätte man den Satz nicht etwas anders strukturieren sollen, weil ich finde, wenn du sagst, ich habe heute schlechte Nachrichten, der Satz wird immer schlimmer. Leider. Wenn du anfängst mit Italien hat sich gemeldet, ich habe leider schlechte Nachrichten, dann glaube ich, würde man das viel sanfter nehmen. Ich finde das auch nicht sanft. Italien hat sich gemeldet. Anstatt, ich habe schlechte Nachrichten bekommen aus was, Italien, ach so. Das ist das Schlimmste, was in Italien passieren kann. Er beginnt ja noch anders, der Satz beginnt, leider habe ich heute morgen, ist direkt, diese Mail ist Horror. Genau, leider ist immer wirklich so das Wort. Leider ist schon das Wort, das die schlechte Nachricht ist. Wenn du irgendwo, ich habe ja mich mal in einer Schauspielschule beworben, und dann muss man da anrufen, und dann fragt man, wurde ich genommen oder nicht. Und man wartet eigentlich nur auf das Wort leider, weil du weißt schon, leider und du weißt sofort, okay, tschüss, ist schon alles erledigt. Du wartest dann nicht mehr, leider, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, wurden sie, ja, ja genommen okay okay okay ich glaube es klappt sie ja ja sollten jetzt ja ja ja auflegen weil sie nicht genommen wollen und sie immer noch dran sind. Read between the lines. Read the lines. Read the fucking lines. Read them. Ja, das ist wirklich schwierig, oder? Das stimmt. Wenn man sich so in so einer Akademie bewirbt oder so, da gibt es dann immer so Videos. Ja, Relatable Humor jetzt, wenn man sich bei einer Akademie. Bei einer Akademie. Wenn man sich bei einer Schauspielschule oder bei Hogwarts bewirbt oder so. Ich rede von diesen YouTube-Videos, wo Leute sich freuen, wenn sie an ihrer Uni genommen wurden, Harvard oder so. Und ich schaue mir manchmal, weil ich finde, du brauchst eine emotionale Balance in deinem Leben. Und für jedes Compilation-Video über Leute, die sich freuen, schaue ich mir auch ein Compilation-Video an über Leute, die es halt nicht genommen wurden. Einfach um es irgendwie, also gar nicht Schadenfreude oder so, aber... Sondern um dein Weltbild, nicht alle werden genommen, gerade zu werden. Genau, damit ich nicht die falschen Erwartungen an die Welt habe. Falls ich mich mal in Columbia bewerbe oder in Harvard oder Oxford, weiss ich... Zählen alle Ivy League Colleges auf. Stanton. Stanford. Stanford. Columbia. Brown. Brown, Baxter, Paxton, Clemaine, Payne, Perrine, Brown, Columbia, Cornell, Dartmouth, Howard, University of Pennsylvania, Princeton, Princeton, Princeton, and Yale. Dreimal Princeton? Princeton, Princeton. Für sechs führende Universitäten unter der Schirmherrschaft der katholischen Kirche der USA wird manchmal der Begriff der Catholic Ivy League verwendet. Dazu zählen folgende Institutionen des Boston College, College of the Holy Cross, wow, okay, die haben nicht in der Berg gehalten, Fortham, Georgetown, Notre Dame University und Villanova. Oh, Villanova. Villanova bei Philadelphia. Ach so, okay. Die Ivy League, okay, ja gut. Ich habe gute Nachrichten aus Italien bekommen. Glaubst du, du studierst noch mal in Italien, in einem Ivy League College? Nee, ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, noch mal zu studieren, weil das war auch immer cool, als ich zwei Semester Philosophie studiert habe, hatten wir auch immer so Rentner mit in den Vorlesungen und die waren immer die allergeilsten, weil die hatten kein, also normalerweise als Student, du hast grossen Respekt vor dem Raum, vor den Inhalten, Kant, Nietzsche, vor dem Professor. Nicht so, wenn du michzsche persönlich kanntest. Genau, nicht so, wenn es dein Mitbewohner war. Und diese Rentner hatten explizit diesen Respekt nicht. Die hatten nicht den Respekt vor dem Professor, die hatten nicht den Respekt vor den Inhalten, sondern meinten, das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn und so hier und da und wir alle so, wir saugen den heiligen Nektar aus den Äonen der Weisheit und die so, hä, das ist doch Quatsch, was soll ich denn so, die wollten ständig diskutieren und der Professor war immer so, wir können gerne drüber reden, aber ihr müsst mich schon mal den Gedanken zumindest zu Ende erzählen lassen, dann können wir drüber reden, aber da war immer so ganz klar, vor allem die saßen immer in der letzten Reihe, was so geil war, weil das wirklich so dieses Schulrüppel letzte Reihe mit so den
Füssen hoch und die hatten so die Rollatoren
auf dem Tisch und so
und das war so eine weirde Dynamik,
weil die jungen Leute
vorne und mitarbeiten. Kannst kategorischer
Imperativ besagt, dass du
nicht wollen kannst, dass deine
Taten zur allgemeinen
Maxime werden, wenn du sie
so siehst. Handel nur so, dass du wollen kannst, dass deine Taten ... Bullshit! Bullshit! Okay, Burkhard hat ... Naja, also, wenn man das jetzt mal utilitaristisch betrachtet, dann ergibt das ja wirklich überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also, was der Kanzler mal gedacht hat, wirklich kein überhaupt nichts. so einer Lebensweisheit um die Ecke, sondern als ich mal, also ich habe ja die Heide geschnitten, der Nachbar hat das, war dann aber sie beschwert, ich hasse ihn ja eh schon. So eine gewaltige Lebensnähe. Boah, das war auch echt, also da gab es viele, so wie es ist, viele Vollidioten auch einfach, die dann, wo du wirklich redest über Kants Imperativ und dann meldet sich einer, naja, im Grunde ist das ja auch so ein bisschen wie bei der Pharmaindustrie, wo du ja die, und du denkst dir, was, wo willst du hier hin, der wirklich in einem grossen Saal mit 300 Leuten anfängt mit, naja, wenn man sich die Pharmaindustrie anschaut, dann sind natürlich diese moralischen Standards nicht auf alle übertragbar und alle nur so, niemand will das, niemand interessiert deine edgy Meinung zur Pharmaindustrie, das ist einfach so richtig unangenehm.
Das glaube ich, aber ich glaube, da ist auch für die Philosophie so ein Magnet für, für so unangenehme Backseat-Gamer.
Ja, so richtige unangenehme Leute, die eigentlich da hingehen und schon alles wissen und dann nur noch allen anderen zeigen wollen, dass sie es schon wissen und dann quasi, naja.
Anders als Podcaster.
Die Leute zwingen, ihre Stimmen zu hören im Schlaf oder im Bus. Weil wir wissen alles. Wir wissen alles und deswegen müsst ihr uns zuhören. Obwohl, ich habe diese Woche angefangen, in mir zu arbeiten, tatsächlich. Es gibt tatsächlich. War Italien involviert? Italien war noch nicht involviert, mal gucken, wie es sich entwickelt, aber tatsächlich habe ich gemerkt, dass ich Defizite habe. Okay, ich bin ganz ohr. Ich war auch überrascht. Ich dachte mir, was? Ich dachte, du bist perfekt. Ich dachte auch, ich bin perfekt. Und tatsächlich geht es in die körperliche Richtung. Ich habe angefangen zu trainieren. Aber geistig bist du komplett perfekt. Geistig bin ich vollendet. Okay. Aber körperlich habe ich tatsächlich noch einen Körperteil gefunden, das noch nicht perfekt nach athletischem Standard funktioniert. Penis. Ne, da macht immer wirklich ... Da macht mir gar keine Sorgen. Ne, ich habe tatsächlich noch meinen Körper betrachtet und habe gemerkt, der kleine Finger, der kann gar nichts. Der ist so klein. Ist das die Story? Ich dachte, dass es normal ist, dass der kleine Finger nahezu nichts kann. Nichts alleine. So, und du schaffst die 90 Grad, also alle Finger sind oben und nur der kleine Finger. Und ich schaffe nicht mal die... Du schaffst gar nichts? Ich schaffe gar nichts. Guck dir das an. Mein kleiner Finger kann alleine fast nichts tun. Wenn du jetzt Pfeffion hältst, dann könntest du ja sehen, dass der kleine Finger nahezu nichts macht. Der kleine Finger und ich schaff nicht mal die... Du schaffst gar nichts? Ich schaff gar nichts, guck dir das an. Mein kleiner Finger kann alleine fast nichts tun. Wenn ihr jetzt Pesseln hält, dann könnt ihr ja sehen, dass der kleine Finger
nahezu nichts macht. Der kleine Finger
schafft gar nichts und
es kommt immer der Ringfinger mit, wenn ich
den kleinen Finger bewegen will. Das verstehe ich, ich verstehe
die Idee. Aber den kleinen Finger, ich kann
den wirklich nicht mal, ich kann den
vielleicht 45 Grad, so
und ich dachte, das sei ganz normal,
dass man halt den kleinen Finger kaum bewegt.
Hier kann ich das, guck mal. Rechts, du bist rechts besser. Aber links kann ich es auch besser. Ja, okay, du kannst es viel besser sehen. Rechts, aber bei mir geht es explizit um die linke Hand, weil ich ja die Tastatur nutze und bei mir der kleine Finger immer ein Problem ist bei der linken Hand und ich kann ja wirklich nichts. Und ich habe Leute, ich habe jetzt wirklich angefangen, Leute zu fragen und manche Leute einfach mit einem kleinen Finger völlig selbstverständlich lose. Und ich habe gesagt, nee. Aber ganz kurz, du fängst gerade an, eine Geschichte zu erzählen, in der du doch dann ein Defizit beschreibst, in dem das so weniger hast als ich. Ich kenne das nicht gar. Naja, wenn du ihn gerade lässt, krieg ich ... Aber ist das so eine Mindset, schwieriges Wort, Frage, dass du, wenn du eine starke ... Luke, benutze die Macht, benutze die Macht, konzentriere dich auf deinen kleinen Finger. Äh, äh, äh. Aua, aua, ist mir doch weh. Und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, was machst du jetzt?
Weil einerseits könnte ich das jetzt einfach akzeptieren, dass mein Körper nicht perfekt ist,
sieht mir aber eigentlich nicht ähnlich.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt angefangen, meinen kleinen Finger zu trainieren.
Kannst du das nicht in der Öffentlichkeit machen, bitte?
Und wirklich, ich saß gestern im Zug und saß wirklich so da
und habe versucht, den Finger zu trainieren. Ähm, Ihre Fahrkarte bitte. Hallo, Ihre Fahrkarte bitte. Sie können mich damit nicht manipulieren. Sie braucht keine Fahrkarte. Sie können mich, was machen Sie mit dem kleinen Finger? Ich brauche keine Fahrkarte. Ich werde nach Hause gehen und mein Leben überdenken. Wir kommen eh nie pünktlich an. Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung, Existenzkrise. Bottrop, Hamm, ein Hals schlimmer als der andere. Was? Was? Ganz recht. Sie haben den kleinen Finger gesehen. Sie haben einmal kurz von der Wahrheit gekostet. Und dann begrüßen sich alle mit diesem geheimen Gruss. Die, die es können. Und ich denke mir so, das kann nicht sein, weil ich glaube, das ist eine Trainingssache. Und ich versuche es jetzt wirklich zu trainieren, dass ich eines Tages will ich den kleinen Finger alleine ganz bis zur Handfläche runterklappen können, ohne dass die anderen Finger mitkommen. Das ist mein Ziel. Und mal gucken, das kann sein, dass das jetzt eine Woche dauert oder ein Jahr oder zehn Jahre. Ich werde dranbleiben. Bleib doch bei anderen Sachen dran. Zum Beispiel aus dem Stand deine Füsse zu berühren mit deinen Händen zum Beispiel. Davon hast du, glaube ich, mehr im Alltag. Aber es ist so anstrengend. Und dass du dich jetzt so überfokussierst auf diesen kleinen Finger, ist kein grosses Problem, was du da hast. Vor allem, ich habe jahrelang Gitarre gespielt, ich habe ein bisschen Klavier gespielt. Ich dachte meine Finger… Kommt das vom Gitarrespiel, dass man da so… Nee. Eigentlich nicht, eigentlich musst du mit der linke kleine Finger, ist ziemlich gefordert bei der Gitarre, deswegen dachte ich eigentlich… Aber nie alleine. Ja, komm drauf an. Alle Finger sagen… Nicht ganz alleine, natürlich. Kleiner Mann, wir haben dich. Ja genau, so ist es ja so, die kommen mit, ich komme mit, ich komme mit, ich komme mit. So der Ringfinger sagt, wo willst du hin, ich komme mit, ich komme mit, ich komme mit. Nee, ich komme mal mit. Nein. Ich nehme ein Stück, ich nehme einen Schritt zurück, aber ich bin immer da, ich bin immer in der Nähe, okay, ich bin immer in der Nähe, hey. Ringfinger, ich bin gross genug. Du bist der Kleinste von uns. Ich weiss, aber darum geht es nicht immer nur. Es geht nicht nur um körperliche Größe. Ich kann auf mich selber aufpassen. Ich gehe jetzt da raus und werde die 90 Grad überwinden. Aber wir kümmern uns um dich, okay? Wir sind da für dich. Aber wenn ihr immer für mich da seid, dann komme ich nie mehr klar, wenn es euch mal nicht mehr gibt. Was hast du gehört? Naja, dass er jetzt anfängt, Holz zu hacken mit einer Axt. Naja, aber das macht doch die Rechte hauptsächlich. Und er hat auch ... Stimmt, die Rechte macht all the dirty work. Ich meine, wir sind eh schon nur die zweite Hand. Du bist der kleinste Finger, der schwächeren Hand. Du bist wirklich das schwächste Glied. Der zweitschwächsten Hand. Ja, aber du bist wirklich das schwächste Glied. Du bist eins von zehn. Du bist eine Eins von zehn, was die Finger angeht. Ich bin nicht das schwächste Glied, wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Oh, ja, aber er hatte die Phase, ja, mit links, ja. Ich meine nur, wenn wir irgendwann mal, wenn ihr nicht mehr da seid, dann muss ich die ganze Arbeit machen, mit dem Daumen zusammen. Ja, aber wir wollen dir ja auch zeigen, wie es geht. Wir nehmen dich an den Finger und wir zeigen dir, wie es geht. Und eines Tages vielleicht bist du alleine auch ein vollwertiger Finger. Hey Leute, worüber redet ihr? Der Daumen. Immer der Aussen vor. Hey Leute, worüber redet ihr? Hey, bleibt doch mal stehen. Hey Leute. Ach Gott, da ist Rico. Oder Pico, bei der Gitarre ist das ein P. Okay, ja cool. Da dachte ich, vielleicht könnte man verbinden. Vielen Dank für den Fakt, ein angesteuertes Fakt, denn hier könnt ihr noch was lernen.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wohin ich damit komme, weil jeder weiss, körperliche Fähigkeiten sind größtenteils antrainiert.
Und deswegen bin ich gerade auf dem Weg und schau, wie es geht, weil es ist ja schon spannend, dass die ja irgendwie Zusammenhängen scheinen, was ja sonst eigentlich nicht ist, dass Körperteile, na gut, vielleicht schon, keine Ahnung.
Aber ist auch, wenn du das so ein Knickst selber, dann kannst du so bleiben, dann kannst du so bleiben, dann meldet sich schon der Ringel, der Ringel will schon wissen, was da los ist, hey, hey, hey, fass nicht meinen kleinen Bruder an hier. Irgendwie merkwürdig, ne, man müsste ja meinen, dass man eine sehr gute Fähigkeit hat, seine Hände einzusetzen. Ich glaube, der kleine Finger ist wirklich nur dazu da, wenn alle greifen, ist er auch dabei. Wenn du eine Axt nimmst, dann hält der auch mit fest, aber der macht nie was alleine. Glaubst du, er entwickelt sich zurück, ist auch deswegen so klein, weil er schon dabei ist, sich zurückzuentwickeln? Die Menschen werden schon mit vier Fingern geboren, das geht schlagartig. Es geht schnell. Ganz, ganz schnell. Die ersten werden schon ohne Nase geboren, die meisten werden ohne Gehirn geboren, weil man mit Chachibiti jetzt alles in denien bringt. Oh, hier sieht man an den Wahlergebnissen. Ooooooooh, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, bo, bo. What the... Wo ist der Anwalt?
Er hat gekündigt.
Hatten wir nicht einen Anwalt, der sich um sowas kümmert?
Wir haben einen Scherzanwalt, der verhindert, dass wir unruhszüge Witze machen.
Aber er ist weg.
Offensichtlich ist er für die heutige Folge weg.
Ich bin gerade dabei und weil ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, man hat ja immer so eine Liste mit Jobs oder Berufen, die man auch ganz doll spannend findet, wo man dachte, wie war mein Leben, wenn ich das wäre? Und bei mir ist ganz oben auf dieser Liste Architekt. Ich finde das so cool. Ich bin ein grosser Fan von so Design und Entwürfen und Architektur allgemein. Und ich finde das spannend.
Ich finde diese Skizzen, die sie machen, spannend.
Ich bin noch nie Modelle, die sie bauen, spannend.
Ich interessiere mich für die Geschichte.
Ich finde das alles toll.
Und aber als Non-Architekt-Guy kommt man selten in den Genuss,
architektonische Arbeit zu machen. Nie.
Ich könnte mich jetzt so sehr einlesen, dass ich ein Haus bauen kann, irgendwo auf einem Grundstück, was man sich dann kaut oder whatever. Nein, macht man nicht. Sondern man ist dazu gezwungen, anderen Leuten dabei zuzugucken, wie sie diesen Traum leben. Jetzt muss ich helfen, weil in meiner Familie zieht jemand um und ich helfe mit der Küche. Ich bin für die Küchenplanung zuständig. Okay, cool. Und der Küchenbau oder der Küchenvorgang, der Planungsvorgang ist so nah daran an Architektur, wie es irgendwie geht, für Leute, die das nicht machen. Und ich finde das so, es macht mir so Spaß, sich da wirklich dann mit diesen Küchenmenschen ewig lang hinzusetzen und alles minutiös zu planen, zu entwerfen, dann so Muster mitzunehmen, das ist genau meins. Geil. Und dann lege ich es hin und denke mir, nee, das passt nicht, das passt. Und dann wird man so büdevoll meint und man denkt, alle sagen mich herum, es ist so eine scheisse Küche, aber ich kann nicht schlafen, liegt nachts wach, dann kommt mir die Idee und ich schreibe sie auch mit dem Bleistift auf. Wenn der gleichzeitig die Schublade und den Ofen aufmacht, dann verkeilt sich das und dann kriegt er nicht mehr das Kabinett auf. Das passt aber nicht. Ich muss ihn anrufen. Ich rufe er wieder an. Ja und dann, also es macht aber so, vor allem dann irgendwann, ist auch nicht mein Geld gerade, was bei dieser ganzen Sache auch noch ein bisschen hilft, aber irgendwann hat man etwas entworfen und dann wird es bezahlt und produziert und dann wird es dahingestellt. Es ist ja so geil und das ist für mich wirklich gerade so ein erfüllender Vorgang.
Aber was ist dein Medium? Hast du da ein Programm oder hast du da ein Stift und Papier?
Gibt Internetprogramme.
Und dann modellierst du das so?
Alles fing an mit meinem Messgerät und Zollstock und Millimeterpapier.
Dann auf diese Onlineprogramme von dem Hersteller gegangen und dann kam ein und so weiter. Man muss ja so viele Entscheidungen treffen bei der Küche. Besteckschublade, wo ist sie?
Ja, ja, wo ist sie? Wo kommt sie hin? Und dann entscheidet man sich sehr schnell dafür, wo sie ist. Aber so eine Küche hat schon eine Intuition. Es ist schon, wenn du in einer fremden Küche bist und sagst, kannst du mir mal den Apfelschäler geben, du nimmst eine Schublade, du hast nicht einen, du fängst nicht rechts oben an und arbeitest dich irgendwo hin, sondern du hast einen Griff und denkst dir, es wird wahrscheinlich, der Apfelschäler ist wahrscheinlich in dieser Schublade, bin schon oft auf die Schnauze gefallen und habe die Pornohefte gefunden. Der Anwalt sollte wirklich zurückkommen. Aber es ist oft so, dass dass es dann auch stimmt als es gibt schon eine logik ich glaube jeder jeder der das gerade hört hat wenn es in einer generischen küche hat eine schublade im sinn wo man erst mal ziehen würde für den apfelschäler ja genau also eigentlich gibt es auch nicht viele schubladen die oben sind und immer eine schublade die oben oben ist, ist schon ein Zeichen für Besteck. Grosses Giveaway. Aber es ist so spannend, weil meine Küche hat zum Beispiel, die ich zu Hause habe, hat keinen Mülleimer unter der Spüle. Und Leute finden den, und das ist ein grosser Mülleimer, der neben der Küche steht. Er ist sehr gross. Aber Leute sind so blind für diesen Mülleimer. Und dann ist so, die laufen dann immer intuitiv, reden mit mir, ja, alles klar, müssen wir morgen mal gucken und dann stehen sie da und machen die Spüle unten auf und es ist kein Mülleimer. Dann werden die Augen ganz gross. Dann werden die Augen gross und sie haben dann irgendwie so eine, weiss ich nicht, so eine, was schmeißt man weg? Serviette. Irgendwas. Mir fällt nichts ein. Was kann man wegschmeißen? Plastikverpackung. Ja, oder ein ähm. Ja, oder halt irgendwie keine Ahnung, so Essstäbchen, wenn man gerade ja oder so Holz, benutzt ja Holz Einweg-Essstäbchen. Genau. Schmeissen sie weg und dann haben sie es in der Hand und machen sie auch ein, stell mal, wo ist der Mülleimer? Und ich sag, ja, das ist einfach der Grosse, der nebensteht. Und sie, wo ist es? Ja, aber ist die Spüle? Und dann fangen sie an, alle Sachen aufzumachen und robben am boden rum bin ich im kummer bin ich im kummer ist es das real stefan sagt mir dass ich nicht im kopf und ich sag ist es doch da vorne weg ich will aufwachen ich will aufwachen ist so ein kräftes mal jedes mal drehen durch und die nachbarn nebenan wieder so klingdong die schreiereireierei begrenzen. Steht neben, neben der Spüle. Aber da merkst du ja, eigentlich du als Designer, merkst ja dann, oh hier funktioniert was nicht. Wenn die User Experience so konträr zu deiner Idee läuft, musst du ja gucken, soll dich hier nicht nachthelfen. Genau, manchmal muss man einfach der Intuition zuarbeiten und sollte sich nicht irgendwie durch Designideen der Formalität, der Funktionalität entgegensetzen.
Was ich glaube, ich noch nie benutzt habe, ist die Dunstabzugshaube.
Ich war noch nie in einem Moment, wo ich dachte, das ist mir zu viel Dunst.
Ich habe auch gar keine.
Das ist jetzt gerade zu viel Dunst.
Dunst.
Das ist, nee, jetzt ist ein Dunstlevel erreicht, bei dem würde ich jetzt eingreifen.
Ich habe noch nie Dunst abziehen lassen. Das Dunstlevel in unserer Wohnung ist so gross, dass ich mich ärgere, dass du nie die Dunstabzugshafte benutzt. Mir ist das zu dunstig gerade irgendwie. Können wir den Dunst abziehen? Können wir, also das ist immer so. Hey Siri, können wir den Dunst abziehen? Zieh den Dunst ab. Zieh den Dunst ab. Rete-teetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetet Nein, nein, nein. I feel lonely, low, low, low, low, low, low, you're the one that's ... Nee, wie ist das? Dunst, I feel dunstig, dunst, dunst, dunst, dunst, dunstig. Aber du hast recht, die benutzt, ich habe keine, ich habe keine. Ja, und geht es dir ab? Nein. Oder geht es dir manchmal ab? Sei ehrlich, sei ehrlich, geht es dir manchmal ab? Ich verstehe die Frage nicht. Brätst du dir manchmal einen Speck, brätst du dir manchmal Speck und du hast dann so richtig schön die Karzinome und die krebserregenden Räuchereien in der Küche und sagst, das ist mir zu dunstig. Ne, hab ich noch nie gehabt. Fenster auf, zack. Ich mag auch das Geräusch nicht. Ich mag das Geräusch nicht, das ist irgendwie für mich so ein Stimmungskiller irgendwie. Und du brauchst Stimmung beim Kochen? Ich brauche Stimmung beim Kochen. Ich brauche immer so, das muss immer so ein bisschen Samba in der Küche. Ja, ja, ich bin der ruhige. Nee, verstehe ich, brauche ich auch nicht. Aber es macht mir sehr viel Spaß, das zu planen, weil ich denke, das ist das nächste an einem eigenen kleinen architektonischen Projekt. Ich habe tatsächlich eher ein schlechtes Bild von Architekten, das liegt aber auch an meiner Erfahrung, denn ich habe im Studium tatsächlich auch natürlich Austausch betrieben mit anderen Gewerken und mit anderen Wissenschaftsrichtungen und da hatte ich zu tun mit einer Statikerin und da waren wir immer so in einer Gruppe mit verschiedenen Leuten unterwegs und die Statikerin hat eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht als ständig über Architekten zu lästern. Das war eigentlich ständig so und es war eigentlich relativ egal, um welches Thema es gerade ging, sie hatte die besondere Fähigkeit, das Thema dahin zu lenken, wo sie wieder über Architekten lästern konnte, und das hat mich durchaus beeinflusst. Und es war dann... Sie haben Staffel Suits, das ist doch so geil, oder? Findest du nicht, Susanne? Sie haben Staffel Suits gestern zu Ende gebincht, das war so geil. Ja, vor allem auch die Gebäude, in denen die sind, diese krassen Wolkenkratzer und so, das ist echt krass. Übrigens, letztens hat mir wieder ein Architekt ein Konzept von einem Wolkenkratzer vorgestellt. Ich dachte mir, ey Kollege, wie soll das Ding stehen? Katze und andere Szene. Wie soll das Ding? Habt ihr Bock, Mittag zu essen? Ich dachte, im Vapiano können wir kurz irgendwie reinstellen, dann irgendwie Italienisch essen, dann später muss ich aber noch zwei anderen Vorlesungen. Das war Piano ist ja in der Richtergaste, mit diesem alten Gebäude, wo dieses alte Gebäude und der Deckmacht schon steht. Ja, da können wir einfach essen gehen. Übrigens, letztens hat mir genau zu dem Gebäude ein Architekt gesagt, von wegen, oh, lass uns da nochmal renovieren und umbauen. Ich so, hast du eine Ahnung, wie das Fundament aussieht? Hast du aus, wie das Fundament von diesen historischen Gebäuden aussieht? Da kann man nicht einfach noch zwei Stockwerke draufbauen, aber du kennst den Architekten. Katze, eine andere Szene. Die Mareike hat übrigens morgen Geburtstag. Da müssen wir uns noch ein Geschenk irgendwie ausdenken. Mareike? Ja, genau, Mareike. Die wohnt ja in diesem Bungalow, ne? In diesem sehr, sehr breiten Bungalow. Ja, genau, die ist das. Gut designt. Da hat jemand mal richtig seine Arbeit gemacht. Das ist ungewöhnlich für Architekten, weil normalerweise machen Architekten immer ihre grössen Hirngespinste und ihre Wolkenschlösser und niemand soll es bauen. Und das war immer so ihr Ding zu sagen, ja die feinen Architekten denken sich ganz tolle Sachen aus, aber denken nicht nach wie, nee nach nicht nach, wie, nee, nach, denken nicht nach, wie das am Ende stehen soll. Das war so ihr Ding. Und deswegen, als du gesagt hast, du wärst kein Architekt, habe ich gemerkt, dass diese Stimme in meinem, dass diese Stimme in meinem Kopf immer noch existiert mit so einem, da ist ein Architekt, der baut da so, wie wär's denn mit einem Gebäude, das wie so eine Basecap auf hat, wo oben so ein riesiger einseitiges Dach, das so ganz weit geht. Und da hat die Statikerin mir direkt gesagt, ja wie soll man das bauen, wo soll die Säule sein, wie soll man das hochziehen, warum fällt das nicht um so, ne und deswegen glaube ich bin der. Vielleicht wärst du jetzt Architekt. Das kann gut sein, ja wirklich. Wenn du sie nicht hängelernt hättest. Kann gut sein. Die hat mir echt diesen Beruf richtig versaut. Und seitdem habe ich wirklich auch immer, wenn jemand sagt, ich bin Architekt, habe ich immer direkt ein schlechtes Gefühl. Aber bist du besser gern Statiker? Dann auch nicht so richtig. Auch nicht, weil ich fand sie auch nicht so sympathisch, weil es immer so sehr meckerig ist. Warum gibt es dieser sehr meckerigen, unsympathischen Frau so viel Platz in deinem Kopf? Tja, ist irgendwie als Stimme geblieben. Aber Leute wirken auch cool, die immer alles schlecht machen. Da muss man so ein bisschen gegen ankämpfen, aber kennt man ja auch irgendwie, wenn ein neuer Film rauskommt und dann ist er eigentlich der der coolste, der sagt, er ist schlecht und scheiße und warum und die Szene gibt keinen Sinn und die Szene und du so, ja, ich fand ihn eigentlich ganz gut. Der, der Dinge gut findet, ist immer so ein bisschen lame und deswegen war das vielleicht die Faszination auch. Ich möchte dich mal was fragen. Warum geben wir den Stimmen, die wir eigentlich gar nicht so mögen, so viel Raum in unserem Kopf? Beispiel. Keine Ahnung. Statiker, die dir in den Ohren hängen. Ja, oder Leute, die einem so, die man nicht mag, oder so alte Schulen-Mobber oder sowas, die was trägst du diese hose die die super feminin ist super uncool und dann zieht man das nicht an zum beispiel mehr klar man will dazugehören aber man mag den ja nicht ja man denkt ja nicht alles der coolste typ und alles, was er sagt, ist richtig und ist total angezogen und deswegen vertraue ich ihm auf jeglichem Level. Vermutlich ist es einfach ein Oh, das Arschloch, ich hasse den und du siehst die Hose nicht mehr an. Ja. Warum, obwohl man Leute dann nicht mag oder so, eigentlich müsste das doch ein Zeichen sein, dass es die Richtung ganz gut ist, weil man mag den Menschen so wenig, dass man vermutlich auf einem guten Weg ist, kleidungstechnisch, wenn er das nicht mag. Das finde ich spannend. Ja, es ist schwierig. Es ist ja die Frage, ob man selber voll dahinter steht oder ob man sagt, da bin ich mir nicht sicher und dann sagt jemand was Schlechtes, dann ist es sofort weg oder es ist natürlich auch so ein, man will nicht ausgeschlossen werden. Es kommen genau zwei Leute an dem Tag zu dir. Einen, den du nicht magst, der sagt, was für eine kacke Hose, die sieht furchtbar aus und dann kommt jemand zu dir, den du sehr magst und der sagt, das ist eine mega coole Hose. Und dann, du hast zwei Stunden an diesem Tag bekommen. Ist es eine Korthose? Es ist eine feine Korthose, ja. Es ist eine rote Korthose. Ja. Denk nicht so sehr darüber nach, was du denkst, wie du sie findest. Ja. Du hast zwei Stimmen gehört und die gleichen sich mega aus, aber du merkst, die polarisiert. Klar, auf jeden Fall. Die schlechte, auf jeden Fall. Ja. Kenn ich ja auch so, YouTube-Kommentare oder so, so du scrollst durch die Guten und dann der eine Negative macht dich fertig und da denkst du lange drüber nach. Und du selber schreibst ja auch keine negativen Kommentare. Du hast ja eine geringe Schnittmenge wahrscheinlich mit, oh, oh. Bei deinem Poetry Slam Auftritt muss ich jetzt dann doch gestehen, dass ich da, ich habe geschrieben, schaut euch den Lauch an. Du warst JerryBear62? Ich war Jerry Bair 62, ja. Er hat gesagt, schaut euch den lauch an du warst jerry bär 62 jahr gesagt schaut euch den lauch an schaut euch den am lauch an habe ich geschrieben das tut mir leid warum hast du nach wörtern gesucht bei einer nachricht die du editieren kannst habe ich immer gefragt ich suche jbeer62 seit vier Jahren schon. Ja, das bin ich.
Warum hast du das Am geschrieben?
Schau dich den, ähm, Laura.
Und es ist auch nicht mal ein guter Hate oder so, weil
alle gucken sich den Laura an.
Ich wollte, weißt du, mir ist es ja
selber auch peinlich, dass ich negative Kommentare
im Internet schreibe, deswegen wollte ich da eher so einen
umgangssprachlichen, äh,
ich denke gar nicht viel darüber nach.
Deswegen dachte ich, wenn ich das Am schreibe. Aber du schreibst, das ist ja was anderes. Genau, aber dann denken die Leute vielleicht so, das ist einfach so
unreligiert. Wenn das jetzt so ein perfekt religierter Text mit Satzzeichen wäre, würden die Leute denken, ich habe da zu viel Arbeit reingesteckt.
Schaut euch den Lauch an, wie ist das den besten Hate-Kommett der ganzen Welt. Vor allem, wir gucken uns den an. Ja, es ist ein Video. Wir alle haben auf das Video geklickt. Ja, aber für mich, ich versuche die Lauchigkeit herauszustellen. Wir alle sehen den selben Menschen. Aber die geht ein bisschen verloren, weil du danach suchst. Es wirkt so, vielleicht ist er noch nicht am Ziel seiner Suche angekommen. Ja, das stimmt. Du musst keine Filme da schreiben, Jerry Bear. Okay, gut, dann habe ich das gelernt, ja. Die nervigsten Kommentare sind ja die, wo einfach noch Information fehlt. Das ist für mich immer, das macht mich immer am meisten fertig. Wenn Leute sagen, ah, du bist fett geworden oder so, alle Informationen sind da, klar, das trifft einen, das verletzt, aber das ist okay. Da ist man nach zehn Minuten drüber weg. Aber wenn jemand einfach sagt, was labert der für ein Müll, dann würde ich immer gerne antworten, was genau meinst du denn, also auf welche Aussage beziehst du dich? Ist ein vier Stunden langer Livestream? An welchem Punkt? In Gänze. Sagt mir grob, geht es um die erste Stunde, zweite Stunde, weil das würde mich ja schon interessieren, was die Person meint, kann ich da nochmal was klarstellen, ich bin ja glaube ich auch zu konstruktiv, aber dieses, was erzählt der für den Müll und ich so, vielen Dank für dein Feedback, aber ich bräuchte es ein bisschen präziser, was, was meinst du? Sechzehnseitiges Formular, wenn du es ausfüllen können, das wäre super. Genau, also was ist Müll im Sinne von logisch falsch argumentiert?
Ihre Definition von Müll.
Genau, also geht es um die Prämisse, geht es um die davon abgeleiteten Aussagen, geht es um die Schlussfolgerung von den Prämissen zu den Aussagen, was genau ist der Müll? Und wie schlimm ist das Wort Müll für Sie auf einer Skala von eins nicht so gut wie zehn grösste Scheisse, die ich jemals gesehen habe? Weil Sie haben ja bei einem Video davor geschrieben, was redet der für ein Scheiß. Jetzt ist ja labert Müll und redet Scheiß. Welche Aussage würden Sie zustimmen? Ist das jetzt? Müll grösser als Scheiß oder Scheiß grösser als Müll? Bei labert ist ja schon abwertend. Also ist es sozusagen zweimal Mittel, labert Müll ist genauso wie redet scheiss oder ist scheiss so und vergessen ihr kommentar wo sie geschrieben der brabbelt nur bla bla bla genau ist brabbeln und labern für sie eine andere kategorie von kritik oder ist damit dasselbe aus so dass es dann und deswegen sind solche kommentare sind tagelang in meinem kopf wohing, ah, der ist fett geworden, das ist eine klare, verarbeitbare Beleidigung, das ist ganz simpel, so, das tut kurz weh, aber dann kann man damit umgehen. Schwerer sind die, wo einfach so viele Fragezeichen offen bleiben, so dieses, was, worum geht's denn hier eigentlich gerade? Ja, aber das stimmt, also mich verletzt Herr Sorge-Kommentant auch immer und ich frage mich dann immer, aber ich habe noch nie, wirklich noch nie das Bedürfnis gehabt, etwas Negatives zu schreiben. Ja, ne, ich auch nicht. Weil man ja auch, das ist gar nicht jetzt so eine Oh, ich bin Sankt Stephan-artige Aussage, sondern man guckt ja oft Videos, die man mag. Also ich habe das noch nie verstanden, warum man Dinge guckt, die man vielleicht nicht mag. Also auch, weil ich selten so, keine Ahnung, politischen Kram oder so gucke. Oder wenn, dann weiß ich ja, was ich bekomme und gucke dann wahrscheinlich eher in der eigenen Bubble nach Kram. Und deswegen verstehe ich immer nicht, man weiß ja schon sehr genau, was man bekommt und so und lebt eh schon in so einer eigenen kleinen, wohligen Comfort-Internet-Welt. Und deswegen habe ich auch das Prinzip nie verstanden, warum man sagen will, keine Ahnung. Das ist ja auch eine Unterscheidung, glaube ich, von der Sprechposition, sagen wir mal. Es gibt ja, also ich glaube, wir denken eher so, wir kommunizieren mit den anderen Zuschauern oder mit dem Produzenten des Videos und versuchen konstruktiv zu sein, wohingegen andere Leute das einfach so, ich stelle mir mal vor, die sitzen vor dem Fernseher und dann sagt jemand was und dann sagt er, was redet der denn für ein Müll? So einfach so in den Raum hineingesagt. Aber das tippen die dann auch wirklich in die Tastatur ein. Aber es hat keinen wirklichen Adressaten. Es geht an niemanden, man will damit nichts erreichen, man will nichts verändern. Es ist einfach nur so in die Welt gesagt. So was sagen, um sich noch lebendig zu fühlen. So in etwa, man sitzt mit Kumpeln auf der Couch oder auch alleine auf der Couch und sagt dann, oh man, den hätte er doch reinmachen sollen. Und dann schaut er jemanden beim Videospielen zu und sagt dann, ah, den hättest du doch reinmachen sollen. Und ich lese so den Kommentar unter einem YouTube-Video. Genau, was willst du mir sagen? Welchen reinmachen meinst du, worum geht's? Aber das will der ja gar nicht. Der hat ja gar kein Interesse an einem Austausch, sondern einfach nur an Gedanken ausdrücken irgendwie so. Und da, das ist schwer, wenn da verschiedene Konzepte aufeinander prallen. Aber auch da, man misst dem sehr viel Wert bei, obwohl man wahrscheinlich keine grosse Schnittmögliche hat mit Leuten, die negativen Kram in Interesse ballern. Weil man wahrscheinlich missversteht, man denkt, der redet mit mir. Denkt mir so, was willst du mir sagen, aber der redet gar nicht mit mir. Er redet in meiner Sprache mit mir er benutzt meine wörter benutzt er hat die gleiche skala von hate wie ich habe jemand der die ganze zeit incident hat hate schreibt oder oder viele kommentare hat vermutlich auch der hat noch der hat noch luft nach oben wenn er schreibt was labert er für den müll Ja. Jemand, der schreibt, was labert er für einen Müll?
Jemand, der schreibt, was labert er für einen Müll, hat noch, da ist noch Puffer für mehr Hate. Und dann denkt man, aber man setzt es gleich mit seiner Skala und seinem Ende. Und was labert er für einen Müll, wäre einer der krassesten Negativkommentare, die ich geschrieben habe. Jemals. Und ich glaube, man muss einfach checken, ah, anderes Individuum, anderer Umgangston, eine komplexe Entität in sich, die man nicht gleichsetzen sollte. Aber da bin ich noch nicht. Und manche wollen auch einfach lustig sein. Also es gibt, oft interagiere ich mit Leuten und merke am Ende, ah, die meinten das als Witz und ich habe von Anfang bis Ende nicht den Witz verstanden, was hier überhaupt lustig sein soll.
Also da geht natürlich auch ganz viel verloren von Ironie und witzig sein und so und die reden vielleicht mit ihren Kumpels so, äh, du Arschloch und so und da hast du jetzt verbockt und so und dann reden die genauso mit einem Streamer und du nimmst es halt, hä, wer meint das jetzt irgendwie so? Die sagen zu ihrem Kumpel, du laberst zu viel Müll und meinen, du bist witzigitzig vielleicht. Das ist vielleicht für die so ein, ah, du laberst nur Scheiss. Ah, der labert nur Müll. Der labert nur Scheiss im Sinne von, ah, mit dem kann man cool Bullshitten abhängen. Und dann sagt er das dem Streamer und der Streamer denkt, was meinst du, was meinst du mit Scheiss, welche Aussage, weil es ist einfach unmöglich. Man sollte einfach nicht kommunizieren. Genau, das wollen wir nämlich damit sagen, hört auf niemanden und haltet eure Klappe. Genau, kommuniziert einfach nicht. Kommuniziert mit niemandem, dann kann auch nichts falsch verstanden werden. Genau, ja. Da, na, man kommuniziert ja auch viel mit sich selber und missversteht sich selbst. Das ist ja das Problem. Wie meinst du denn das? Wie meinst du denn das gerade? Was meinst du denn damit? Naja, jedenfalls bin ich jetzt sehr, sehr stolz auf dieses neue Projekt und ich bin drin. Ich bin jetzt in der Innenarchitektur. Aber hast du wirklich Visionen? Also ist es für dich jetzt nur so ein Abarbeiten oder denkst du halt auch nicht, die Küche muss nochmal komplett neu gedacht werden? Also was ist denn eigentlich eine Küche? Man sagt ja, die Küche ist das Herz des Hauses. Würdest du das unterschreiben oder würde es ein anderes Organ werden? Nein, definitiv. Es ist Herz und Hirn des Hauses. Es ist der Gedenkapparat, es ist der Salon. Dann ist man da aber sehr verwundbar. Herz und Hirn im selben Korb, würde ich erst mal sagen, ist gefährlich. Eben. Und wenn man das versagt und in der Konstruktion versagt, dann kann man die ganze Wohnung wegschmeissen. Und deswegen freue ich mich, dass diese Person zu mir gegangen ist und hat gesagt, Stefan, kannst du das mit der Küche in die Hand nehmen? Und ich sage ja. Aber weißt du was? Ich werde es dir zurückzahlen. Das ist so eine Ehre, dass ich mit dieser Küche aufbauen, weil das Herz, Niere, Gehirn und Hauptpulsschlagade, so wie diese Bauchaorter der Wohnung. Ja, die Bauchart. Und was würdest du sagen, ist das Schlafzimmer? Ne, Nasenflügel.
Schlafzimmer ist der Nasenflügel. Der linke Nasenflügel des Körpers. Was sind die Augen des Körpers? Küche, auch Küche. Auch Küche, okay, am Ende. Und deswegen freue ich mich so, dass du mich beobachtet hast. Und mein Bruder Jerry mit dem Wohnzimmer. Ja. Was, wo ich sage, ist die Sohle, die Fusssohle, die Wohnung. Du nimmst Küchen schon sehr ernst, ne? Also das ist für dich schon ... Ja, ich habe diese Aufgabe bekommen. Wie viele Stunden verbringst du in der Küche so pro Tag? Nicht so viel, aber ich habe diese Aufgabe bekommen. Ach so. Und ich möchte es umsetzen. Ich wollte eigentlich, meinte nur, dass du beim Ikea meine Bestellung abholst eigentlich. Ja, genau. Aber das, du hast mich mit dem Hauptbestandteil der Wohnung. Weil du ein Auto hast, du bist der einzige von uns, der ein Auto hat. Deswegen war die Frage, ob du kurz zum Ikea fahren, also die Bestellnummer ist alles da, du müsstest nur hinfahren und es abholen. Du hast es schon bestellt? Ich habe es schon bestellt, ja. Kein Problem, ich turniere es einfach direkt, weil ich mache es, ich werde die Aufgabe annehmen. Wir haben alles, wir haben alles turniert und du müsstest wirklich nur hin und... Clara, das ist das Coolste der Welt. Ich wurde noch nie mit so einer grossen Aufgabe betraut und ich möchte dir zurückgeben. Und dann so ein paar Tage später, ne, eigentlich Wochen, Wochen später, Liefertermin wurde lange überschritten. Ja, zwei Jahre später, die Küche ist jetzt fertig, Clara. Ich bin stolz, ich hab die Küche neu gedacht und das ist sie. Und dann ist so mega arzi und abstrakt. Ja. Wo ist der Mülleimer? Der steht daneben. Warum kann er nicht einfach da sein? Er steht da, guck mal, er steht mitten im Raum. Was ist denn eigentlich so, in den USA gibt es oft diesen Müllschlucker. Ist das was, was du vermisst oder wo du sagst, weil eigentlich ist das ja richtig geil. Ich verstehe nicht genau, was du damit meinst. Du meinst in der Spüle, die sind sehr kleinere. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was es ist. Noch nie hatten wir sowas, als wir in den USA waren, noch nie haben wir sowas gesehen, dass man so eine Art, was ist das, eine Müllpresse oder so eine Art Häcksler, der dann so die Essensreste zerstört. Aber wo geht das hin? Das geht dann auch einfach in den Abfluss, oder was? Das wird ganz klein gemahlen und geht dann in den normalen Waschbecken Abfluss. Weil eigentlich ist es ja mega geil, so Essensreste direkt wegzuschreddern oder so. Ja, finde ich auch super. Müsste auch Platz sparen, aber auch gefährlich. Du brauchst du nicht den grossen Häcksler in der Küche, wo du sonst die Sachen reintust.
Ja.
Also vielleicht sind das noch Möglichkeiten, die noch offen sind. Ich glaube, du denkst immer noch zu klein. Du denkst immer noch in der Schublade. Ja, das stimmt. Ich denke mal, beim Mülleimer wäre geil, wenn es so ein, oben hat das dann so eine Druckluftpresse, so eine Hochdruckpresse.
Und du schmeißt was rein, dann geht er zu und dann Druckvorgang läuft und dann wird das so platt, der Mülleimer, und dann wird das so platt gedrückt dazwischen, so eine Walze und du kannst den Mülleimer wirklich so ein Jahr lang benutzen, mit dieser einen Tüte, die du drin hast, weil das alles platt gedrückt wird, es wird so, so viel Energie geht aber auch drauf, und dann so Stefan, unsere Stromrechnung für die Küche, die du konzipiert hast, ist irgendwie, wenn die bezahlen, das ist hundertfache. Und vor allem, 90 Prozent der Energie geht in diesen Sprecher. Es ist nicht mal die Druckluft, sondern es ist diese Lautsprecher mit dem Sprecher. Ja, ich habe Werner Herzog beauftragt, zu sagen, dass der Druckvorgang ... Verbraucht das so viel Strom? Also das, ich verstehe nicht, warum dann ... Ach so, nee, das ist einfach nur so ein Schaltkreiserror. Ach so, Druckvorgang läuft, Druckvorgang läuft, Druckvorgang in Betrieb gesetzt. Grüße gehen raus an Werner Herzog, das kann man auch nochmal sagen. Wir wissen ja, dass er den Podcast hört.
Ja stimmt, du hörst den Podcast regelmässig.
Liebe Grüße und meld dich mal wieder. Vielleicht kommen wir zu großem Podcast-Ufo Weihnachtsfeier, kommst du mal rum. Da haben wir alle mit dabei, Oli P ist am Start und dann machen wir eine schöne Sause, wenn du Lust hast. Meld dich, du hast noch ein bisschen Zeit, ansonsten sind wir kurz davor abzuheben. Wir verabschieden uns von euch, wünschen euch viel viel Spaß, vielen Dank für alle Einsendungen und die Beleidigungen.
Reddit-T-Rex-Taskforce, die am Start war.
Ich habe es im Internet gesucht, nicht gefunden,
habe gemerkt, alles findet man viel schneller im Reddit.
Also besucht so einfach mal reddit.com slash das Podcast UFO.
Irgendwo ist dann r slash noch mit drin.
Das kriegt ihr schon selber hin.
Ihr seid ja nicht bescheuert, denke ich mir manchmal.
Vielen Dank. Also besuch doch einfach mal reddit.com slash das Podcast UFO, irgendwo ist dann r slash noch mit drin, das kriegt ihr schon selber hin. Ihr seid ja nicht bescheuert, denke ich mir manchmal.
Vielen Dank.
Ansonsten vielen Dank an dich auch, Florentin.
Gerne, vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze, dass du heute wieder mit dabei warst.
Gerne. Vielen Dank und wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Sehen wir uns.
Bis dahin haben wir eine schöne Zeit, weil wir wissen, die T-Rex sind wieder ein bisschen zu Hause und bis dahin ... Du suchst den Vibe, abseits vom Standard? Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt. Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde. Klingt anders? Ist es auch.
Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta.